[Music]
good
all right hello pill poppers we're
bringing you
a special edition of micro dose it's me
victor
the formerly known as the politics guy
but maybe that's not an appropriate
title anymore since really we have two
politics guys
in a sense and i have the other one with
me matt mcmanus that
we want to today we want to just focus
on someone who is probably not
considered
to be traditionally in the critical
theory tradition and i would say
probably people who are informed by the
critical theory tradition
generally are perhaps critical of him
rawls of course and we sort of want to
talk today about
why we think he's an important figure to
consider if you're
if you're interested in radical politics
uh why he has more critical potential
than maybe he's given credit for
and sort of why we think some of the
critiques of his might be a little bit
unfair
um so i'd like to begin by asking you
matt um because i know that a lot of
your work is
pretty influenced by rawls and um
i i myself am pretty influenced by rawls
even though i come at things from
a more continental perspective but you
have a book coming out and uh
which is definitely influenced by roles
so maybe you could talk a little bit
about that
sure um so the book that's coming out is
liberalism and liberal rights uh
critical legal argument
uh with palgrave mcmillan uh you wrote
the introduction for it also
yes uh not exclusively a single author
project
now we got a hail mary assist on that
one all right so before
diving too deeply into uh rawls's
thought
i want to just offer some context so
maybe matt
how would you situate uh what roles is
doing with relation to what you how you
what you understand liberalism to be
broadly and in what way is he a liberal
a liberal well raul's relationship to
liberalism changes significantly over
the course of his academic career right
early in his career he tends to frame
himself as a kind of tantian liberal
who is emphasizing both the importance
of individual autonomy
but also you know the relevance of
looking
at moral issues from a relatively
abstracted or impartial standpoint
right right but giving it a bit more of
an empirical twist
later on when he talks about political
liberalism what he means is that the
principles that govern society have to
be endorsed
by people who hold a wide variety of
different metaphysical views
and that includes countions but also can
include people from
different religious backgrounds atheists
marxists you name it
pretty much anybody who doesn't hold
what he characterizes
as a fundamentally unreasonable
viewpoint um
right but i guess just like at a more
basic level though would you say like so
he's a liberal because would you say he
emphasizes
like the individual or um i don't know
like how would you define if you were
just defining
like liberalism in a basic way yeah like
in how he is one
i think the reason that rawls actually
can be characterized as a liberal if
you're talking about it from a very
principled perspective is that
at the epicenter of his work is the
notion that all people are fundamentally
moral equals
right uh and they're entitled online
basis to equal respect
uh and the problem with their society as
it exists right now
is the fact that our society doesn't
treat people as moral equals uh we still
tend to evaluate
individuals from this very meritocratic
standpoint
and suggest that certain people deserve
where they wind up being
because they either lack certain natural
talents or they lack certain attributes
of character
and rawls is going to resist this very
strongly now that doesn't mean that he
believes
that everyone should be equal in fact
and this is one of the things the
difference principal tries to capture
but it does mean that we should operate
from the presumption that
equality is the best thing to achieve
and any deviations from that
need to be justified rather than just
taken as being natural or inevitable
right doesn't he doesn't he prioritizes
the right over the good
right meaning i guess which like how
would you define that well that's a
complicated question right
but it does relate back to the issue of
moral equality because
fundamentally what he's saying is that
all people being more equal
doesn't necessarily mean that each
person is going to do
live as fruitful or flourishing a life
right and that's because
moral equals might decide that they're
going to engage in very different life
plans
uh or aspire to very different life
goals some of which may be more worthy
of our veneration than others
right um right so for example somebody
who decides to spend their life
counting is it is it like counting
counting like that like the blades of
grass was that an example
exactly you know somebody who sits there
and has this idiosyncratic uh desire to
count all the grains of sand in a beach
uh or every grain of
uh like every blade of grass in a field
of grass uh that might be a life plan of
some sort and you know all power to you
but we would hardly call them as worthy
of reverence
um or you know respect uh as somebody
who sat there and produced great words
of poetry
or produced um penicillin or whatever it
happens to be
right but by his argument for the
priority of the right over the good
is that it's not the state's job to try
to arbitrate between these life plans
and suggest that we endorse one of them
over the other
and the reason for this is because royal
thinks that the kind of experimentalism
that's shown
when people are free to decide what they
think is worthy of veneration
and pursue that without interference
allows
a variety of different viewpoints to
emerge and we all benefit from that
right and then to some extent this is
key this is key to the answer to the
question of what makes him a liberal
right because like that's a very liberal
move to make
to prioritize the right over the good in
a way absolutely and i think that
you can see this reference um in joshua
mills right
the notion that experiments on living as
mills puts it
are beneficial not just to the
individuals who are engaging in the
experiment
but to all of us because we can all draw
if you want to put it
on the data that they accrue over the
course of their life right uh and that
doesn't mean that everybody who engage
in edges
and experiment and living is going to
wind up successful right
some people might realize that the kind
of experiment that they undertook was
actually really
misinformed uh are probably not the most
advisable thing to do but then we learn
from that as well
right exactly so i think um yeah i mean
i think that's that's key to to
understanding what makes him a liberal
right he wants to set those questions of
like what a good life is
like how do we morally evaluate like an
end kind of uh
rank different quote like kinds of life
we have to set that question aside in
some ways he wants to say they're not
relevant to
how we're going to design a just regime
and we have to just think about
prioritizing like giving people the
equal opportunity to do things and i
think that's
a good way and then one more one more
thing just to like get out of the way
before we get into the nitty-gritty is
just
there's obviously this idea of the
original position and the veil of
ignorance
and i feel like maybe we should just
explain that maybe people who are
familiar with rawls took an undergrad
course probably know about what that is
but it's probably important just to give
a very basic understanding of what what
we mean by the veil of ignorance or the
original position
sure of course uh so ross's notion of
the original position is an effort to
try to
capture the essence of what he thought
was insightful in the contractarian
tradition right
and the original position is a situation
where
reasonable self-interested actors are
supposed to deliberate
on the principles of justice that would
organize society
and after they leave the original
position whatever principles they chosen
will be the ones that
uh organize society and they'll have to
live with their choice
okay uh the veil of ignorance is a
restraint he puts on the capacity of
these individuals
to know who they're going to to be in a
very concrete sense of the word
uh so raw says that the problem with the
way that a lot of us reason morally
is that we're way way way too partial
to trying to benefit ourselves or trying
to advance
our own viewpoint uh based on our
history our value system or whatever it
happens to be
uh and this all precludes uh making a
more objective kind of judgment right
and the argument that he makes is that
okay so say we want to put people in
this original position where they have
to deliberate upon and choose the
principles that are going to organize
society
what we'd want them to know would be
things like the basic principles of
economics
we want them to be self-interested and
know that they're self-interested
we want them to know certain important
features about human psychology
and we want them to know how to read and
so on and so forth but we wouldn't want
them to necessarily know things like am
i a man or a woman or am i rich or poor
am i gay or straight uh the problem
being that
if they had access to this kind of
information it would be all too easy for
them to
try to hedge the system to their benefit
uh
and try to create a society that would
versus privileged men
uh over women uh or would prevent so the
veil of ignorance is just
is just the thing that is pretty it's an
it's the name he uses to
to say that this is the restraint in on
the knowledge that people have exactly
that's what the veil of ignorance part
exactly
it's a constraint on the kind of
information that's available to
reasoners
because rawls feels that this will
produce more impartial outcomes
uh and right even though the people
behind the veil of ignorance will be
self-interested
because they don't know what who they're
going to be once the veil is lifted
they'll be more capable of deliberating
upon the principles of justice
without giving into their biases and
prejudices
sometimes sometimes i find it useful
like an analogy to think about if you're
splitting up a cake
and then it's like you know that you're
not going to get to pick which piece
so that incentivizes you to split the
cape cup as evenly as possible
because you're not going to get to pick
right i don't know if you know there's
like some i i've sometimes thought of
that as an analogy if that makes sense
no
that's exactly right i mean uh raw
sometimes appeals to this metaphor right
by saying
one way that you try to think about this
is what's the proper way to cut a cake
right and it would be very easy to sit
there and say well
i'll just give myself the biggest slice
and to die everyone else a piece of cake
but he says what happens if you have to
give everyone else a slice first
and then you get the last piece uh well
in that kind of circumstance
you'd probably be more inclined towards
allocating people equal shares
uh because you want to make sure that
since there's a lot yours is the last
piece that's going to be given
uh you would have the same kind of
slices everyone else right
of course and of course it gets much
more complicated in a political society
but that analogy is kind of an idea a
way of
knowing about the kind of work that that
ignorance
because you're not going to know where
you end up is doing it incentivizes you
to try to think more fairly
exactly right uh and that's why rawls
like these kind of metaphors and thought
experiments right
i mean some people have criticized him
for this by saying that well he's
abstracting away from
who human beings really are and what it
is that they do
um but his point is that well listen
like to a certain extent we
obtain a certain moral clarity uh
precisely when we dissociate
from our concrete interests in this way
and try to reason impartially about
what would be the most just thing to do
and
all too often he says we fail to do this
precisely because we're so embedded
in whatever it is that we're doing that
we only think of justice as being
whatever is beneficial to us at any
given moment
and for obvious reasons that's not a
particularly helpful way of approaching
the subject matter
so they have to think to themselves um
what would
uh since since i don't know what i'm
going to be out what if i end up being
you know a low-income black woman or
or whatever other marginalized group how
would i want society to be set up what
would the rules be and essentially it's
from
this thought experiment that rawls
argues he arrives at his principles of
justice which we're going to discuss
first
the reason why i take raw seriously is i
think that rawls captures something
radical uh in the liberal tradition that
isn't always acknowledged by critical
theorists
and this is the idea that moral equality
is the central
value uh that different societies are
supposed to try to respect
and his argument in some respects is
that
liberal societies have done a good job
advancing uh the principle of moral
equality
over authoritarian regimes in the past
whether you're talking about slave
societies or feudal societies
but in some sense they're handicapped by
their exclusive focus
uh on justice from a formalistic
perspective
rather than looking at what's
necessarily uh to lead a good life
right different resources honors and so
on
uh and we can get into the kind of
details of his work
but where he's really innovative is by
attaching liberalism to an argument for
redistributive justice
in particular by suggesting that people
behind the origin the veil of ignorance
and the original position
would select to redistribute goods
uh so that any inequalities would only
be permissible if they were to the
benefit of the lease while off
right and there are several primary
justifications he gives for this
some of which you know are stronger than
others the big argument that i think is
really convincing
uh and really persuasive uh is this kind
of devastating hit
against what's sometimes called the
workman ideal which is very
prominent and moralistic justifications
for
classical liberal capitalism or
neoliberal capitalism
in the contemporary time period and this
is the argument that
people are entitled to what they have uh
under a market society because they've
earned it uh in some mysterious way
right that it's a just dessert uh for
the reward or the effort they put into
things
uh along with being talented and
intelligent and so on
uh and rahul's argument is that if you
actually break down
why it is that people earn whatever it
is that they earn in a capitalist
society
whether you're talking about earning
very little or earning a lot uh for the
most part it's for what it calls morally
arbitrary reasons
right that have nothing to do with the
choices that people make
and his critique is so devastating that
he even goes on to say that
you can apply this mode of reasoning
when talking about the effort
that people commit uh to trying to
become successful
and he points out drawing on a number of
empirical studies that have
been backed up that even if you look at
effort and striving
a lot of that is determined by having
fortunate family and educational
circumstances early on in life
not to mention having a substantial
degree of natural talents uh not being
disabled and so on
uh and these are all things for which
you can claim no credit um
and the argument when you take all this
together uh is that not only
is the notion of earning or deserving
something uh in a capitalist society
not a really uh compelling moral
argument uh it starts to look actually
incoherent
if you're talking about dessert from
any kind of conventional moral
standpoint that says there's some
association between who you are and what
you do
and your moral qualities and what you
get
yeah that makes sense i think um what's
uh maybe i'll
back up a little bit because i'm
interested because i guess thinking
about
rawls uh as having critical potential
because i agree with everything you said
you said i think it's important it's an
important line of critique it's a
powerful line of critique and
especially since today in america we
still see these
ridiculous arguments from the right who
just talk about people need to make
better choices
or whatever and like you know they they
don't uh
really acknowledge the unearned sort of
positionality that people are in whether
it's a good positionality or a bad one
right so they they always just talk
about everything being choices and i
think
rawls does a good job of showing of
providing an argument for why like
that's
doesn't really uh doesn't really exactly
make sense and i think the way he does
this by the way which is the thing i
want to bring it back to
is right like the original position
which i think most people probably know
the basic argument but i guess to me i
sometimes have thought about this as a
form of critique
that might even be like a kind of
eminent critique right which is sort of
a um
sort of a foundation right of critical
theory right the idea being that uh
that if you want to measure it you met
you you you check a society and see how
it's living up to its own standards
and i think to some extent maybe like
before rawls we talked about
formal equality and you know legal
equality
but i think what rawls does a good job
with with his device of the original
position
is to show why maybe society's not
actually living up to those principles
and i think i don't know maybe
do you want to give a uh a quick like
summary of what of
how the original position works sure and
i would say i think that you're exactly
right
and rawls isn't subtle about this either
uh i should say
right uh particularly in the first
edition of theory of justice he situates
himself in the broadly cantian tradition
which is obviously a critical condition
that suggests that
we need to analyze not just our
interpretation of the world
and our interpretation of what's right
but under what conditions we can say
things are right or wrong
in the first place and when you start to
do that it
beheads a lot of the ideological
justifications
for heteronomy or the status quo that
the powerful like to invoke to try to
justify
their honor and privileges and resources
right yeah
but just putting it really briefly right
rawls's uh thought experiment has been
subjected to
a huge number of different critiques and
analysis um we don't want to get into
all that because you'd be here all day
but putting it really briefly he
suggests that we should try to imagine
what it would be like
uh if we had to actually formulate
something that approximates a social
contract
right uh he says if you think about the
contractarian tradition
uh of lockhops and rousseau it seems
pretty obvious that there never was an
actual state a social contract
where we move from the state of nature
into living within
civil society it's not even clear for
that matter that hobbes lock rousseau
ever say there was actually a social
contract
but you know if you look historically
the closest thing that you can get
uh would be for instance something like
the american founding uh where people
did actually
create a constitutional convention uh
and try to formulate what the principles
organizing society was going to be
but of course you know the american
social contract and i put that in
quotation marks
i excluded women the unpropertied uh
african-americans and people who are
white and so any kind of claim that well
this is reflective of what everybody
wants or would agree to
uh even at the time uh it's just bogus
right and if that's your kind of
exemplar of historical social contract
taking place
uh it's not a very good one right yeah
uh so raw says well why don't we take
this idea seriously then
and say there was a social contract
historically
but what if there was one you know what
would people choose
as the governing principles to organize
society he tries to stipulate certain
conditions
for the kind of reasoners who will be
assessing what these principles are
and this is where the kind of kantian
elements of his argument comes in
because he says look you know one of the
problems
with conventional social contract theory
is if we take people simply as they are
most of us has vested interest
we reason about things ideologically a
lot of the times we don't actually think
about
the principles that we would hold to all
that critically and of course you know
economic
factors play a major role uh in
determining what we think happens to be
right or wrong since rich people tend to
think that
they've earned their wealth in some way
shape or form and they're not very prone
to
thinking about that all that critically
right uh so he says
we need a more impartial set of
reasoners to actually determine what the
best principles were going to be
otherwise the only contract that we're
going to get
is something of a mess and it's not
really clear why we should find it
morally compelling
and the kind of weird but actually
strangely
intuitive argument he makes is well
let's imagine
a series of reasoners who are
knowledgeable uh or rational
in the sense of being aware of the basic
laws of human psychology
being aware of a lot of the basic laws
of economics
being self-interested and that's quite
important uh so that
and also also being aware of of the fact
of pluralism or maybe that's in
political liberalism but i think that's
an important one too like right like the
fact that people are different
oh absolutely right being aware that
they hold uh that different people hold
different moral outlooks
uh and they're gonna be aware of all
these things uh but the
avail of ignorance is going to descend
uh this is the other part of his thought
experiment
and they're not going to know uh who
they'll wind up
being from a more concrete perspective
right
so they'll know that they're
self-interested beings but they won't
know if they're a self-interested rich
person
or self-interested poor person uh
they'll be aware of the fact that their
pluralistic world views in society
but they won't know if they're a
religious fundamentalist
uh or if they're an atheist uh or if
they're agnostic
they'll know that they are likely to
inhabit one of two genders
and walls is a bit anachronistic here
right but they won't be aware of whether
or not they're a man or a woman
uh or straight or gay and i mean now of
course we could just plug in transgender
as an option it's i think going to give
you a similar
yeah like it's not that much of an
alteration to just include that also i i
don't think so and i mean
the nice thing about the veil of
ignorance right uh is it's inclusive of
all these kinds of differences in
particularities uh
exactly exactly right so he says you
know once you put this veil of ignorance
down
you have these people who are rational
they're knowledgeable uh they're
self-interested but they're not aware of
the concrete specificities of who they
happen to be
and his argument is that given these
circumstances these individuals will be
able to make
a more impartial uh choice about the
kind of principles that they'll want to
govern in society
and right they reason they deliberate
amongst themselves and they propose a
variety of different alternatives for
the kind of society
they might want to have and a number of
these rawls excludes just offhand
because he says it's pretty clear that
the majority
or even you know the vast majority
people would reject them
and this includes living in a slave
society uh living in a feudal
aristocracy
nobody would really want to live in
those in the 21st century
because it's quite likely that they
would wind up at the bottom rung of
society
and a very few people would wind up at
the top and also these societies don't
happen to be particularly
effective at producing wealth uh so even
if you do happen to wind up at the top
you're probably not going to be as well
off as you would be uh living in a
better
organized decision and he also of course
then he of course wouldn't want uh like
even today's society right
sorry like to cut you off but i'm just i
want to kind of emphasize i think it's
what makes the critique powerful right
like today especially against these sort
of conservatives that i was talking
about right who uh
who make who say just make better
choices like i think from this
perspective
right they'd say they would have to ask
themselves oh crap if i had to make a
choice
like right now think about the life of
like a poor black woman right what i
want to this is
the rules to be what they are today
right and i think the self-interest
would make them realize well no
because like it forces i think it forces
intuitions
that you have to admit that certain
things are like unearned choices
i just want to throw that in there to
connect it back to the last thing we
were talking about absolutely right and
one of the things that's unique about
rawls in this respect
is while he does give a straightforward
moral argument um
for why it is that you don't want to
live in a liberal capitalist society the
form we live in right now
uh it's the moral arbitrary witness one
that i've mentioned before we'll get
into that
uh he also does make a self-interested
argument to that effect
uh where he says you know if you are an
impartial person behind the veil of
ignorance
and you were self-interested you didn't
know who you were going to wind up being
no sane individual in his mind would
decide to gamble
that they'll have a 100 chance of
winding up a millionaire
if they have a 1-2 chance working at
mcdonald's right
yeah not being able to support their
family um and there are some people who
have tried to push against this by
suggesting
well maybe people would gamble behind
the veil of ignorance in the original
position
but there doesn't seem to be a lot of
good psychological evidence to support
that i should say
uh since a lot of research into
political psychology suggests that
people are
risk averse uh rather than most people
anyway yeah it doesn't seem reasonable
to suggest that i agree
yeah exactly right and this is all
supportive of brawl's standpoint
but you know lost our short right he
goes through a number of different
alternatives
for society the one that he thinks is
the most compelling competitor
to you know what he calls justice's
fairness which is his own preferred
set of principles for organizing society
uh is utilitarianism right the doctrine
that you
try to maximize aggregate happiness and
i don't think anybody really wants us to
go through like all the objections he
has to utilitarianism yeah definitely
not
long story short he doesn't think that
uh people would be willing to take the
risk that they live in a utilitarian
society since
they might be uh end up being uh on the
chopping block
uh if losing happiness with them would
be utility maximizing overall it's
putting it really simply
uh but he says you know impartial people
would choose two principles uh of
justice
uh that i'm calling justice's fairness
right uh the first one would that be
that people have
an equal scheme of basic liberties for
all uh conducive with the same basic
scheme
for everyone else that's the first
principle uh and then the second
principle
would be uh survived into two parts that
offices
and positions would be open to all under
conditions of fair quality of
opportunity
uh and then the really important one
which is that any socioeconomic
inequalities in society
uh could only be justified if they were
to the benefit of the lease while off
uh which is probably actually not
probably it's by far the most
controversial uh element i was thinking
uh because this is the one that really
has a strong egalitarian connotation
and it's actually probably the place
where he gets attacked from both the
left and the right
oh yeah because he's because he's
allowing for inequalities it's just that
those inequalities have to benefit the
worst off
exactly uh and there are a lot of
interpretations about what this would
mean uh you know
what does it mean to say that you know
impartial people would choose to benefit
the least well-off first and foremost
some libertarians bleeding heart
libertarians have said that
well maybe a genuinely capitalist
society
uh not a kind of weird uh capitalist
plutocracy like we live in right now but
a genuine capital society would benefit
them more
but rawls his own opinion particularly
near the end of his life when he
published his book justice's fairness
uh was that actually even a welfare
state um
cut wasn't sufficient to realize the
principles of justice's fairness
uh because a welfare state still allowed
too much inequality
so that's a pretty radical argument
right when you think that sweden uh
isn't going far enough
right uh and yeah exactly argument is
that his ultimate position
seemed to be that we would need to
redraw society
uh and push it towards either being what
he called property owning democracy
um or a liberal socialist society uh
and he never actually says which of
these he prefers
uh but i think before we get to the
before we get to those though actually i
kind of wanted to
flag something else which is um you know
the
the the the veil of ignorance as a as a
critique or as a
as a form of critique i think it's
important like because we're kind of
coming at this from the from a podcast
that is largely like
critical theory oriented and also you
know for those who don't know this
divide and philosophy between analytic
and continental philosophy i don't want
to get too into that
but i think to some extent obviously
critical theory tends to be more
continental and i think
uh which emphasizes maybe less less of
like a rational actor
at the center of of like political
theory and i think sometimes rawls gets
accused because of his device of the
original position
as you know positing some kind of a
rational agent or that human beings like
people i think make a mistake
that like you know the parties the
people behind the veil of ignorance are
like these perfectly rational people
but i just kind of wanted to flag and
say you know like like sort of my read
of the original position
is that it's not so much that they're
being rational
but like if you if you deny like the
validity of the of the original position
in a way i think effectively what you're
saying is that moral imagination is
impossible
because in my in my opinion what the
device is doing is it's forcing you to
imagine what it would be like to live as
somebody else
right and i think that like if if you
can't do that like if you're saying that
that requires some
magical rational agent then like moral
reasoning is impossible and like
how can you even argue for like marxism
or whatever other like left-wing
position if you can't
because i think our ultimately i don't
know if you'll agree or disagree with me
matt but ultimately i think like
your moral uh reasoning has to be or
like your arguments for a different uh
state of affairs or a more just society
need to be based or founded on like
pointing to examples to where you can be
like being that person would suck it's
unfair that that person is like that
and i guess i just want to like defend
that like underneath it all is actually
like in my opinion a quite simple moral
intuition
uh that shouldn't be that controversial
but because of how formal it is
i think brawls often gets accused from
bicontinental philosophers of oh you're
like
you're an individualist like you're uh
you're a um
you know an atomist and you believe in
some sort of rational actor and i just
kind of wanted to present
why i think from a continental or
critical theory perspective that need
not be
how we read rawls i don't know if you
want to say something about that no i i
think that's true right a lot of
continental theorists
have tended to find that raw as a
difficult figure to kind of deal with
probably the most obvious example would
be someone like slavajijak
who every now and then references rawls
in his book but has never actually
offered a very substantial rebuttal
beyond suggesting that he thinks envy uh
is a kind of persistent feature of human
psychology
and he can't get rid of it uh under the
conditions of kind of rawlsian
um what he thinks is a role in social
democracy right uh and again i think
he's wrong about that
but i should say in line with the
comment you make about an imminent
critique
right i think that there certainly is an
element of rawls that's suggesting that
you have to kind of dissociate yourself
from your own specific partiality to try
to think from a more universalistic
standpoint
because raw says well okay let's take
seriously the idea then that people
are self-interested actors uh the way
that
many defenders of the capital status quo
say that we are right that were in it
for number one
first and foremost right uh raul says
you know
if you were genuinely an impartial
self-interested actor
uh behind this veil of ignorance and you
didn't know who you were going to wind
up being in society
uh you if you were a self-interested
person you would not want to live in the
kind of society we live in right now
uh because you'd wind up so likely to be
at the bottom uh rather than one of the
few people who wind up at the top
so it just wouldn't be a sensible bet to
make and the kind of contention he makes
is if you take this contractarian
argument seriously
which is that we want principles that
would be acceptable to all
under rational conditions of fairness
where you can deliberate and decide on
principles and have to hold to them
then that's a serious knock against the
argument for
unbridled capitalism or even welfare
state capitalism right
uh on its own terms since truly
self-interested people wouldn't choose
that
if they were behind the veil of
ignorance exactly and i think that's a
pretty powerful objection right um
so i should just say that that's one of
his main objections
uh to the argument for unbridled
capitalism right that's not what
um people would choose behind the veil
of ignorance if they were
self-interested actors
uh and to be honest i don't know anyone
who's actually been able to offer a
particularly compelling
argument against it um the only kind of
argument
uh that sometimes works uh as people try
to make an empirical claim which is that
well
if we actually take the difference
principle seriously and what we want is
to benefit the lease while off
um maybe a capitalist society is what
does that but i think you know
it's pretty clear that that's not true
right there's a lot more that we could
be doing
uh for the poor than we're doing right
now you know at best you'd want a
society that look at least at the very
least one society
that looks a lot more like sweden rather
than contemporary united states or even
canada
right all right in terms of looking
after the poor since it's much better
off
you're much better off being low income
there than you are and here
and actually so so rawls is two
suggested regimes you mentioned before
right like the property owning democracy
what was the other one again
they're all socialism liberal socialism
right like those i don't know if we can
get into like a little bit about
those but i think you know they they
don't eliminate market exchange
altogether right so there would still be
some form of capitalism in in
at least maybe the property owning
democracy i can't remember
yeah absolutely i mean this is
contentious right uh because
rawls never elaborated at great depth um
about
the specific institutions uh that would
be needed to realize his principles of
justice right
uh which a lot of people have criticized
before and i think justifiably
right um i my own criticisms uh of him
uh when it comes to the problems with
when it comes to him undervaluing
democracy uh
particularly the workplace conocracy uh
as a precondition for maintaining uh the
principles of justice over the long run
right
uh particularly against reactionary
backlash uh but you know a lot longer
show what he seems to mean by a properly
only democracy and again
there's just a few comments on this in
justice's fairness a restatement his
last book
uh is that effectively rather than the
means of production being owned
um by private or corporate actors they'd
be managed
democratically right and that doesn't
mean there wouldn't be private property
any longer uh since obviously people
would have an entitlement to personal
property
in fact you know he would say that we
might even need to take that more
seriously by saying that um
since many people don't have a great
deal of personal property like a home
uh there are obligations to redistribute
well so that they'd be entitled to a
certain level of personal property
uh that's a necessary precondition for
them having self-respect right now that
makes sense actually i'll just
add a little like addition just to sort
of plug for my own uh dissertation
supervisor
peggy cohen her book is actually about
um uh
property uh specifically like real
estate and and housing and stuff like
that and she sort of makes this argument
that um
that when you live in a city right now
we kind of assume that when you own
own a house like you own it so you have
the right to that property but i think
the argument she makes is like but what
made that house valuable was all the
other people around it
right like the fact that the city is
vibrant and that people move in next to
it
and she sort of argues that that doesn't
mean obviously you take the property
away but it means that everybody sort of
should have some sort of benefit
from the property values going it
shouldn't only be the property owner
since it's not like they're responsible
for that property value going up
so i don't know there seems to be some
similarity there oh i absolutely think
so right and this is one of the things
rawls draws our attention to again and
again uh which is that oftentimes
fortune or misfortune
owes a tremendous amount uh to factors
that are well beyond our control
and are morally arbitrary right which
i'll come back with too later on because
i want to kind of
hit this point over the head a little
bit uh okay but i mean he's
he's absolutely uh insistent on kind of
knocking down the egoistic conceit
that everyone's in control of their own
destiny uh in a free and equal
marketplace and they rise and they fall
on their own merits right uh rawls
thinks that that's a myth and
extraordinarily harmful myth uh whether
you're talking about people who feel
that their homes have a certain
intrinsic value to them
uh regardless of what's going on in the
rest of the world uh or people who think
i worked hard
for my money which is why i'm entitled
to 200 billion dollars uh you know
japanese
case or whatever right uh but you know
the property-owned democracy thing just
to get back
uh yeah he seems to say that again most
of the means of production would be
managed uh
democratically uh it doesn't get into a
great deal um
on what that would entail and he seems
to sometimes think that this would be
managed uh by the state
right uh i would push against that a
little bit and contend that actually
what we need is more forms of workplace
democracy
that aren't quite as state-oriented as
well seems to think it was appropriate
and there be need to be more management
from the floor uh because people who
live and work in these kind of local
particularities
uh will have a better insight as to how
things should be managed
than uh exactly yeah right i gotta say
this sounds a lot like these
you know nominally marxist economist
richard wolff
right who says uh his main argument
really is workplace democracy like he's
not even calling for some sort of
state-owned
or state-run communism he just says and
he's calls himself a marxist
and his main argument sounds a lot like
this which is just that bring democracy
to
the workplaces and and uh since since
the the employees should have a stake
but there would still be corporations
they would just be more like co-ops
and they'd be competing against each
other in the marketplace it's just that
everybody who works there would actually
have a stake in the decision so it'd be
more democratic and
by his uh reasoning he thinks it would
be more just
yeah absolutely right uh and the
argument he makes is that you know in a
property owning democracy
uh they'll also be competitive firms
right you know they'll be encouraged to
compete with one another reduce goods
and they'll find a prize and fall
uh based on whether consumers are
willing to buy their products no
it's not people are gonna be told you
know this is what's available and you
have to get it
but all this will be managed by the
demos rather than by
private actors or corporate actors right
the argument for liberal socialism
uh is also equally vague um but it seems
to be a contention that
things would go even further than a
property owning democracy right uh there
would still be
a political democracy in place different
competing parties
uh people would still be permitted to
enjoy all the standard double rights
but private property and power would be
even more distributed than it would in a
workplace democracy
particularly at a more local level uh to
ensure that
there'd be no recalcification of power
for authority
in any private hands and
resources and goods uh would
be redistributed not just through the
industrial or the work sector
but probably also by the state to make
sure that everybody particularly
off was entitled to a very high standard
of living
and the only inequalities that would be
permitted again uh would be those
subject to a very strict
expectation that they were to the
benefit of those at the very bottom
right right and i like yeah
sometimes when i think about the
difference principle i often think about
how
like i imagine i don't think i'm sure
this isn't actually how it would
probably work but i remember
like you know when i was first learning
about rawls in undergrad i remember kind
of like imagining this
court like a supreme court that would
somehow have these tools or like these
legal tests
to see whether or not um these
inequalities like let's say a
corporation a co-op or something ends up
having all this money in the bank and
it's just sitting there and then you'd
have like something some sort of like i
don't know financial
like forensic financial investigator
look and be like okay like is this money
benefiting
the war stuff i mean maybe that's not
how it works but i remember that's kind
of how i would imagine it working which
kind of like cracked me up seemed like a
bit impractical but also like
interesting to imagine and of course i
mean it makes you think about all the
money that
corporations have that are just sitting
there doing stock buybacks and you know
to some extent they're really not
benefiting
uh society or certainly not the worst
the worst off
yeah absolutely right i mean if you
think about somebody like um
jeff bezos or elon musk right uh and
their contention now that
uh i think it was elon musk who said
this right you know i have they have so
much money right now that the only thing
they could possibly spend it on would be
space travel
right yeah yeah now you know a strict
defender of the market might say well
you know if they decide to build rocket
ships and go to the mar and go to mars
uh that'll generate jobs it might
generate new technologies it will
improve
uh people's quality of life overall uh i
don't think brawls would argue against
that right again
uh rawls recognize that there are
certain situations where
inequalities can benefit the least while
often versus by rewarding people who
are innovative uh i create technologies
that help the poor
but i would say you know if you think
about the kind of gross disparity
between
those kind of lavish displays of wealth
and the minimal benefits they accrue
uh with what you could do with 40
billion dollars 60 billion dollars or
whatever
to benefit the poorest people in your
society let alone the world
right there's another question about
whether these kind of principles could
apply nationally
right it's very clear that this is very
far from a just set of
organization uh because you think about
you know billions of dollars you know
that could provide tens of thousands of
people hundreds of thousands of people
with a dignified life uh for the rest of
the days not to mention
established institutions that would
benefit future generations uh for
instance by providing a higher quality
education
better maternal care you name it right
yeah i could i could imagine under this
view like uh
maybe a pretty generous basic income
right it would be like a
maybe be part of like a socialist uh
liberalism whatever
it's possible right again he doesn't
really talk a lot about how this has
been to be
uh carried out or implemented right uh
which is an unfortunate defect in his
work
you know rawls was a political theorist
in the most
capital p capital t sense of the word
right yeah
aside from a tour of duty during the
second world war uh
where he lost his religious face quite
an interesting story uh he spent his
life in
academic analytical philosophy large
parts of his work are technical
responding uh to debates that a lot of
people probably wouldn't find all that
interesting
uh frankly even strict rosians usually
don't find them all that interesting
right
but i think the central animating idea
that the people that we have an
obligation to are the least among us
right and that our society spends way
too much time catering
um really to the people at the top right
and venerating them and praising them
for activities for which they can claim
no real credit
uh that's the kind of moral force of his
objection uh and i think
it's become even more pertinent in the
21st century
as people like the idw who you've
written about really gracefully
uh try to make all these kind of
arguments for competence hierarchies
uh or revering people who have high iqs
just because and all the innovations
that they bring and so on and so forth
rawls would sit there and of nothing but
not scorn because it was a particularly
scorpical god uh but you have nothing
but bad things to say
about the kind of artifice that's
required to hold on to these kind of
ideologically vacuous viewpoints
yeah totally i um you know it's funny i
mean i
i know that rawls is certainly a kantian
in a lot of senses but i think uh what's
interesting and there's been a few books
that have been written about this
that actually trace him as being quite
influenced by hegel that i think a lot
of people don't
don't really realize and i think like
maybe where that comes through right is
when he talks about things like the
social bases of self-respect
as being like a necessary condition of
justice so what he means by that is just
like
uh so there's these things that that he
refers to as um
primary goods which are kind of like the
things that need to be distributed
that's the thing that we're calculating
like what needs to be distributed in
order for justice to obtain
and he talks about how the social basis
of self-respect is sort of like
something that the state is gonna
instill
or like the society the the regime
um and i think he has like interesting
things to say about
um when he's talking about the social
basis of self-respect like sort of the
consciousness of citizens like it's kind
of underemphasized but he does talk a
lot about
you know that people will feel um when
they see that the rules are fair
right they're going to become like and
somehow better citizens there's a kind
of like moral perfectionism and i think
it's in in any case whether it's a gay
or not i think it's interesting that
there's a kind of underlying civic
uh virtue in in roles that is often not
very emphasized where he talks about
like
citizenship and participation and that
like there'll be some sort of
psychological impact on citizens i'm not
sure if i find this necessarily
convincing
when they see that the rules are fair
they'll be better citizens in a way and
i'm not sure if you had thoughts about
that
yeah i know i think he actually writes a
great deal about this in fact you can
make a pretty strong argument
that his second major book political
liberalism uh along with a lot of the
other affiliated papers
uh deals with this almost exclusively uh
over several hundred pages
right uh and this is a response to a
variety of different criticisms of a
theory of justice
uh particularly people have people like
michael sandell in his book liberalism
the liberals limits of justice
uh where these figures argue that well
rawls is kind of repeating
the canteen problem right of viewing
people as atomized individuals
in this case who are purely
self-interested who are trying to will
moral rules uh in this case the
principles of justice
from this kind of removed standpoint and
we don't like that and we think that
it's subject to all the kind of problems
that befell kant's philosophy and as you
pointed out that hey goal in particular
criticized very effectively and i don't
think that that's an accusation you can
level against rawls
at least not to the same degree you can
level against it and level it against
can't
right um and this is one of the things
he points out right that the last third
of a theory of justice
took up the question of what it's like
to live in a political society
uh and what the good as he calls it of
justice would be
in association with other people uh but
political liberalism
really makes the argument that you're
talking about uh which is that
over time if people regard their society
as fair
and as operating according to a
reasonable conception of justice
then they're going to regard it as a
cooperative association to the benefit
of all
rather there's one where they simply
live or inhabit what he calls
a modus vivendi yeah which i think is an
interesting claim uh because
a modus with vendi uh is in some senses
the kind of old marxist um
argument about living in an ideological
living in a society where there's an
ideological superstructure rewritten in
the
late 20th century uh because of emojis
or vendi is a situation
where you recognize that you are
alienated
from the society in which you live you
there's a state apparatus in place
uh to prevent you from questioning it
too
strictly uh let alone from rising up and
trying to change it
and you may well resent this or you may
think that things need to be changed
but ultimately and there's nothing that
you're going to be able to do because
you think that the cost
of trying to establish a more just
society will simply be too high
right yeah and rose's argument is that
liberal society as it exists right now
particularly uh the usa at the turn of
the 20th century
is very much just does uh just have a
lot of people
who live according to a more mere modus
vivendi right yes people feel really
dissatisfied with the society they live
in they want it to change
uh they feel that it's unjust and that
it's not a cooperative
association for the benefit of all uh
that it's to the benefit primarily of
the one percent
and i think those problems he was
describing are much worse now like i
mean i think people feel what he was
describing at the turn of the 20th
century
much more acutely now yeah i know
absolutely i mean we have a bill
there's a billionaire reality v star as
a president right uh just exactly
massive tax cuts uh to all of his
buddies uh
and we can't blame him for covid right
but you know we're sure we're bearing
the dark fruit of that now
uh when you know there's millions of
people who are starving who have lost
their job and there isn't any money to
support them right
exactly but you know rose's argument is
you know we should we can do better
and we should do better and if we do do
better uh then eventually people
in a very hegelian vein right we'll
start to associate
themselves with the principles of
justice within their society exactly
they'll develop what he calls an
overlapping consensus
uh that this is the kind of society
or cooperative association they would
want to live in and what he means by an
overlapping consensus is that
you might uh be a religious person uh
who believes in
the catholic uh view of the good and the
right
i might be an agnostic but both of us
will look at our society and say you
know what
this is a just society yeah
that doesn't necessarily mean that
everybody within the society is just
or that bad things don't happen uh since
individuals of course still make bad and
malicious choices
right uh you won't get rid of the
hannibal electors of the world or
whatever right
yeah but the principles of justice
animating it are good yeah sometimes
i've thought about this as kind of like
there's there's those trust in
government polls right and i think and
to some extent this would be like a very
magnified int like um kind of um
emotional feeling towards the the state
or the society that you
feel a great deal of trust right and of
course the highest trust societies are
like the scandinavian ones and i think
maybe what he's imagining is like
you know this even higher level of trust
where people kind of like oh yeah like i
trust the society i feel like i am
getting what i need
and then they can go about their their
business in other ways maybe it's not so
much that they'd be
necessarily like um uh like love and
uh like their their uh the principles of
justice in this like deep way but they
would just like trust
that's at least how i've thought about
it i don't know no i i think that's
exactly right i mean
rawls uh draws this distinction between
the right and the good
that's pretty common to liberal theory
generally right and there's a lot of
criticisms you can make of it and
we won't get into that here right but
his argument is that
the benefit of liberalism uh and of the
kind of egalitarian liberalism he's
arguing for
as everyone would have the resources and
the freedom and
the social self-respect at the very
least to pursue
a vision of a good life that they
thought was appropriate to them
exactly right and his argument isn't
that well
under these conditions everyone will
ultimately achieve the good life
that's appropriate to them since part
and part that's an individual quest
right if your goal is to find spiritual
solace in you know
the arms of god uh or you know to
liberate yourself from the cycle of
samsara or whatever it happens to be
well politics is probably not that much
of a guide for you right
in some sense you're engaging in a quest
that's independent
of the things that political philosophy
or politics generally can deal with
right but certainly we can enable you
and empower you
in that quest and under those conditions
you'll be able to pursue it far more
effectively in tandem with other people
if that's what you wish
you can all benefit and i think this is
a million point right
uh if you are successful in your pursuit
of the good life uh because we can learn
uh from the achievements and the
failures that accrue over the pursuit of
this endeavor
good yeah so before i know you you've
got limited time so i so i do
kind of want to get to this last point
which is um
i want to bring up like the ways in
which this is different from like a
marxist
and now because i think that you know
given that the this podcast is more of a
critical theory oriented and you know we
often get accused by
our uh compatriots on the podcast as
being liberal cucks
you know i think that it's you know it
would be maybe important to to draw some
sort of lines and be like in what ways
would we be
would people who have maybe more remarks
at their critical theory bent
uh where would they see that we're going
wrong or
or um or see a big difference well i
think that there are two things to say
about that
right uh one is that marxism at least in
its classical formulation uh
particularly as articulated i'd say by
angles rather than marx
uh is presented as a descriptive uh
theory of how it is that society
operates
right uh and in principle it doesn't
make moral or normative evaluations of
that society
uh it says that these are the kind of
norms or more is appropriate to a given
epoch in history uh the liberal
capitalist epoch uh
but we claim that the imminent
contradictions inherent within it are
going to bring it down
and it'll be replaced by a communist
society right uh and rawls doesn't
reason that way right it's not that he's
indifferent to history
uh it's just that he says there is a
place for
moral critique purely moral critique
right
and i think he is right about that right
uh and i think actually for that matter
uh if you look deeply enough in the
works of marx uh it's very clear that he
also has moral criticisms
of capitalism although in his later
works they're not often presented that
way
uh particularly in the kind of arguments
very young hungarian arguments
about how under capital uh our species
being is mutilated
uh and we're not able to realize all
sides of our personality
uh as self-determining beings right i
think it's hard not to look at that as a
moral critique
right yes and rawls does something makes
a similar claim
right uh except his argument is that
there's a
different way uh of formulating that uh
and that's by trying to
theorize about what the best principles
governing society would be
uh and then to check the society you
live in against
uh that society uh and i think you know
some marxists can criticize that well
ideas don't turn the world around
economic relations do
right uh this is the kind of comment
about the thesis on furback
but i think you know marx is probably
just wrong about that there is a place
where ideas
can resonate and can make a difference
uh and move people forward
uh and i think rawls his arguments are
done as much to contribute to that task
uh as anyone
uh the thing where i think marx comes
out better than rawls uh at
uh is in his critique uh of the actual
conditions
um right of liberal capitalist society
uh again you know rawls was a political
theorist
capital p capital t uh you know he's
leveling a moral critique
society he doesn't spend a lot of time
analyzing actual material conditions
doesn't really spend any time looking at
history has very little to say
uh about the twos and froze of even
conventional day-to-day politics in his
day i think he made something like one
or two
public uh contributions uh weighing in
on supreme court issues and so on
throughout the course of his life right
and so if you're looking for rawls uh
to give you a picture um it was descript
about of how your society operates
the power dynamics within it uh square
points
not a good source yeah you're not gonna
find it there right
agreed and you know i think he would say
well that's not what i'm trying to do
but sometimes that produces deficiencies
in its work and you know you and i have
talked about this before
right for instance i think one of the
deficiencies in his work
is precisely on this point of workplace
democracy right rawls kind of takes a
very statist approach to things
at points uh even when arguing for
property only democracy uh or liberal
socialism
and he doesn't have a lot to say about
workers movements for example
i think though that workers movements
are vital if they're even going to
preserve
property-owned democracy or liberal
socialism
because if everything's oriented by the
state that gives capital too much leeway
uh to kind of try to seize control uh of
the state apparatus
and re-entrance its power right you need
to build base level institutions
that are sufficiently powerful enough to
maintain commitments to the principles
of justice
over time and make them stable and rawls
does talk about this a little bit but
not nearly as much as you should right
and i guess if and and yeah for sure and
i guess if we had more time you know i
would want to bring up um
what's his name g.a cohen right and say
that there's also this difference about
uh about like the forms of equality
inequality that we allow in a society
i mean he's kind of a weird marxist
because he's an analytic marxist so i
don't even know if other marxists would
necessarily agree with him or not
but i guess maybe we can maybe we can
talk about that another time
yeah and this is where i actually think
it's a good place to end actually
raul's principles can even be more
radical uh than certain moral
interpretations of marx's doctrine
uh right because cohen's moral argument
uh is essentially that people are
exploited right
uh the workers produce most of the goods
in society through their labor
that's appropriated by the capitalist
class and then sold for profit
and this is wrong because they in a
certain sense are really entitled
uh to the goods that they produce and
this is a pretty forceful moral
objection
the problem is uh you know there it's
pretty close uh
to the arguments of bourjois political
economy uh which just
inverts this relation and says that
while the capitalists are actually the
ones that produce
most of the value uh and so therefore
they're the ones that should get most of
the profit right
uh rawls's argument is in some cases
more radical i think
uh and a lot of people reject me saying
this but it's because he says this is
all a matter of indifference it doesn't
matter
who produces the value in society right
because
say you're able bodied and you're able
to work well not everyone's able to do
that some people have disabilities or
some people that deny this because
misogynistic or patriarchal institutions
right it doesn't matter how hard you
worked
because if you are able to work hard
that's probably of the result of
circumstances for which you can claim no
credit
right uh so all this stuff about later
is secondary to the fact
that what we should be doing is working
to the benefit of the least while off
uh because i'm making yeah yeah and
making focusing on fairness
yeah and focusing on fairness uh because
any argument about labor
is always going to imply that it's okay
for some people to have a lot more
uh even an immense amount more if they
work harder
right right now that makes a lot of
sense yeah and wall says it doesn't
matter if you work 100 hours
and someone works 20 hours right if that
person can't work can only work 20 hours
because they have a disability and you
work 100 hours
you still have to help them right yeah
right and i don't think the subjection
flies against cl marx himself uh but it
does fly
pretty staunchly against the kind of
moral marxism that you see articulated
by people like cohen
which is vulnerable to a lot of the
libertarian objections raised by people
like nozick and so on
okay all right awesome awesome that was
that was that was really interesting i
hope uh the
listeners got something from that i know
rawls can sometimes not be the most
interesting of people who are more uh
emphasize the critical theory or
historical
approach to philosophy but yeah we
certainly think rawls is an important
figure so
thanks everyone for listening yeah and i
should say uh his books are pretty dry
and technical
and often really boring if you ever
decide to get to go through it uh
i applaud you because there's a ton of
stuff to learn there but no one's going
to give him
writer of the year award um it takes a
long time but like once you get into a
system i actually started to find it fun
but it takes a lot of time
it does all right thanks
[Music]
you